before we begin I just want to make a
comment as to why I'm gonna do this by
long division first even though I know
how to do synthetic division and these
are the perfect kinds of questions for
synthetic division just have a look on
the right hand side of the board with me
when it comes to methods in mathematics
you learn like I've got all these
different ways that I can do something
right you need to understand how they
relate to each other so for instance
when you think about long division and
synthetic division one synthetic is
clearly faster but at the same time it's
also more narrow ok it's faster more
efficient it's a less error-prone
generally but it only works in some
cases namely where you have factors or
rather divisors exactly like this
they're linear you know and X minus 1
etc right and also they're monic that
number at the front of the X the
coefficient is 1
ok that's the case where it's really
useful long division is slower less
efficient but it's broader it works in
all cases right so therefore synthetic
division is not a replacement for long
division right it's just another tool
you want to have in your belt it's a
great tool to have but doesn't do
everything long division does then you
need to get this relationship it happens
all the time already looked at one
quadratics remember you first know how
to factorize a quadratic really really
simple ones right and then you look at
harder ones where you can't factorize
you can't pick up numbers because they
like surds and all that kind of thing no
one's gonna guess a certain there pair
of numbers okay so that's why we learned
completing the square and then using
that we develop a quadratic formula now
in exactly the same way quadratic
formula even though it's like wow great
I don't have to think about I just like
put the formula down and substitute my a
B and C in the quadratic formula is
still not a replacement for these skills
right factorizing sometimes you need to
always be able to factorize something
has nothing to do with the quadratic and
secondly completing the square you often
need to do that the classic example is
if you get
an equation like this one sorry just
thinking - fifty now I know you haven't
really seen him encountered equations
like this much before but can anyone
guess if we were trying to graph this
what would you guess that that it would
look like it's going to be a circle
right in fact what this is is like an
expanded jumbled up version of this kind
of thing right X plus something squared
y plus something else squared and then
you've gotten all radius squared over
there it's just been all well I expanded
the bracket so then everything has been
mixed up okay now to unmix them to go
from here to here the only part that you
have is completing the square the core
data formula I'm not going to help you
okay so as a result these methods here
even though they're like ah they're
better in some ways right they are not
replacements for the earlier methods we
still needs to know how to do long
division okay so as a result and also
for the benefit of anyone who runs you
miss Tuesday's lesson I'm gonna do this
one by long division and then we'll do
by synthetic just to confirm we got it
right okay so do we get long what's the
first thing I'm gonna write down having
already set up the division process what
am I going to put it right at the top
it's gonna be a next sweat right because
the question I'll answer is how many
times does X fit execute the answer is
exquisite you multiply it back yeah now
what do I do
I'm doing a subtraction here right so
there's a double negative 15 you're
trying to avoid actually so minus 3 X
plus x squared that sounds like minus 2
x squared to me bring down the minus
seeks X and now what the process begins
again doesn't it right what am I gonna
write at the top minus 2 X 2 in Queen
that's
I see okay multiply back which gives me
minus 2x squared plus 2x okay do another
subtraction which leaves me with minus
8x mutah negative 8x minus 2 this is the
last one how many times would go in
minus 8 and then I'm doing this last
step to work out okay this is going to
be minus 8x plus 8 so this is minus 10
it looks like to me what is that - it
indicating it very good the remainder
saw stick that up here okay so you
simply confirm that make sure we know
what we're doing here what is the number
I'm going to write at the front while
still water yeah it's the it's the
number right there - whatever that
number is okay and then I write down my
coefficients so we're gonna go 1
negative 3 negative 6 negative 2 okay so
if you missed Tuesday then hold on to
your hat for a second I'm not going to
explain this right now you can go back
to when you go back to someone else is
going to see if I'm just gonna go ahead
right I told me if I go right first up
up I just write it down okay and now
begins my repeated my cycle right
multiply add multiply and multiply did I
nail it x squared minus 2x minus 8
remained up negative 10 looks good to me
okay
so that's good I'm done now this next
question that I've asked you calls back
to your function notation language right
when you see this P of 1 was that me in
this context very good it's a
substitution step right so this is how
I'm defining Peter polynomial so P of 1
means everywhere so our next I'm gonna
stick a 1 in okay so let's just quickly
do that
this baby of one okay so let's give this
a crack I'm just doing straight
substitution into this guy right so
that's going to be one cubed which is
one take away 3 times 1 squared which is
1 take away 6 lots of one take away -
yeah let's just tidy it up a little bit
one take away through you take away 6
take away 2 3 6 and 2 are 11 right so
that's one take away 11 which is minus
10
now what play and puppy have to do with
each other I'm not going to tell you
just yet we're gonna do C and D first
before I do that
but you should always scratch your head
a little bit where you see one math
question right with multiple parts then
do it seem to have anything to do with
each other right they do have something
to do with each other it's like that's
all that's what I'm testing for can we
can we dig a little deeper and see okay
is there a connection key and why is
that connection okay let's have a go at
this time we're gonna go straight to see
big because it's you know a hundred
times faster let's go to C okay help me
out what numbers am I gonna go for this
is the sneaky up cuz I gotta close to
here right yeah I'm gonna put down
negative - that's my number out the
front da da and then out come my
coefficients they're the same ones that
I had in the beginning right so one
negative three negative six negative
- okay this time I'll slow down you can
help me out a little bit okay first step
is I write down I just write down the
leading coefficient has one okay and he
comes my cycle step the one I repeat
over and over again which is multiplied
- right and then add what's the sum of
these two
okay good then I multiply which gives me
10 and then iPad which gives me full
very good last one multiply excuse me
and then I add which skews me okay
you happy with that now remember we did
all of this with just the coefficients
so I need to translate don't I right so
again we're dividing a cubic by a linear
factor right so what you're gonna end up
with just like we had here and here is a
quadratic right so this is going to be x
squared take away 5 X plus 4 remaining
anytime you happy with that okay now
let's just quickly have a crack at the
last question P all negative - okay
again it's just a straight substitution
let's see what happens okay you see how
up here even though it's kind of like it
seems like there's a bit unnecessary
because they're not right put you in
with just one right like why did I
bother right now once wait is one okay
well the idea is I want to demonstrate I
know how substitution works okay so
that's going to help me down key where
it's a little more complicated so I've
got my X cute that's the best a
substitution I've got my three x squared
there's my second one six X minus two
thank you happy with that just look okay
can someone give me in the next line
what is -2 cubed now watch out watch out
there's 2 cubed which we know is 8 but
there are 3 minus signs that come along
for the ride make 3 of them two of them
are going to cancel and that leaves you
with just 1 right so minus 8 ok here we
go - 3 times this is minus 2 times minus
2 which is 4 minus 6 times 2 which is 12
and minus 2 you could with that how are
you feeling did I do it too quickly just
make sure I get this again right minus 2
times minus 2 times minus 2 that gave me
negative 8 minus 2 times minus 2 that
gave me 4 here I didn't have lots of
mimes two's flying around so I just did
those two together and that gave me 12
and then the negative 2 is hanging out
on the end you happy now yep ok I'm
almost there
um I see that this guy here and this guy
here are just negative they can use on
each other
yeah so I think they just came to that
okay that leaves me with minus 8 minus 2
cut off I'm done